[Applause]
so yeah I don't know if you guys have
you already I did with a spark in terms
of flow so basically if you have you
figure out that the packet file is not
compatible with the tongue-twisting saw
framework so for that there are some
rock around that we will explore and
after I will give you some suggestion -
to have a look on so basically the first
picture that I'm going to present is
like you have a spark a spark arrestor
so popular stories is - is many to do
pre-processing data at scale and I've
told you you have a GPU server which is
a separate from from this popular store
and basically is more formal training
for especially for deep neural network
so here is a kind of stack for data
science so India is like is the provider
for the GPUs anaconda is like the
pattern to Python packages tensorflow is
the fan what made developed by Google
for deep learning especially and buy
stock is the is open source project from
a definition for two purposes the data
so guys if you have what what is the
cycle to deal with a from a package
fight to in to ingest it in Newton's of
Ramudu so basically you first you
generate pocket fighters so we are you
are happy with your data how you have
been reposted no data and after that
what you want to do is use those data to
- for the model training so for that you
need to to move your data so basically
if if you have nothing between the two
server you can use left after you can
you can build an architecture like you
can put an asset appliance on the GP
saga and month month from NFS protocol
to the spot roster so like that you can
use your data both from GP server and in
the spot waster and so for that when
once the sacrifice
what you can like as I see as we see
before is a first language development
platform for in-memory data so what what
is nice as well is that is a bit like
tufted file is a cocoon oriented and
it's optimized with the back simply
spruce back in libraries so for that
what we are going to use it is a popular
table so basically you map your pocket
right into into aho data structure and
once you have done that what you can use
the that does rejoin to a pad a data
frame but is not really a panda is both
is the kind of pandas in a memory
because maybe you know the back end of
pandas is there an MPR a so after that
you can you can use you can use it for
your turns of limited by using a
defeating feature so as some of you
knows the feeling feature is more for
this for testing your explore its octave
explore is not very well optimized for
that if you want to do tons of remodel
at a prediction scale you need to use a
tons of flow recap file so for that
basically you have tools a nice tool
that I've been developed by you bet and
this the second one I think is from
tensorflow I'm not sure so basically a
does he works the second one first
because you can come back easily a
pocket file it with ricotta file but
after all you don't have a lot of future
to manage your top 5 we speed up some
what you can do basically is a you can
map it as a Africa file but as well you
have like some nice IPI to use with
stencil OOP I Tosh and pure Python
Python console I don't want to have a
look on that after that I just wanted to
show you some code but I don't have
access to the Wi-Fi so it will be a
static presentation I don't know
yeah so basically using cough counter
instead of F sink suppose if here I have
a kefka service which is running on the
sparkle ester and what we can see the on
the GP server that can see the spark
cluster and so basically I have a cough
cough reducer so this is where the data
are coming from and so I'm using the
package file this kind of packet file so
and after are using a catcall consumer
which is running on the G on the GPU
server and basically through this I can
I can send the data very quickly between
the two servers so you can see here's my
features and and my and my lab a legend
and I can find back the data and here
it's just to throw something quickly you
can map your your pocket [ __ ] word it
were tons of wake up file so the data
structure is the photo file is like
serialization made by Google to ingest
your data
ultimate option to measure the defeat
defeating of your data in your turns off
model so this is a photo data switcher
Florin will be on the pub afterwards
dessert you've got any questions thank
you very much and so we've got two two
community announcers I think we're
brewing the paper there was one of the
back you weren't very emphatic please go
ahead sir hi i'm jason and i work at FAL
tech we run a monthly meetup called the
agile data meetup and the next one is
one week on Thursday and the two
speakers are Matthew Roderick and the
title of his talk is energy data is
finally open to innovators which is all
about smart meter data and the second
speaker is Phil Marshall and it's called
a moment in time captured and that's
about a very high resolution 360 degree
camera with light depth that's used at
crime scenes and things like that and
that'll make you think about the amount
of data that you've got to do machine
learning on so come along to that week
on Thursday and it's near angel to just
about a five-minute walk from there okay
feel free to post them to the discussion
group on the meetup Channel and there
was one down there somewhere please go
ahead and have quick follow one hi very
quickly if you are looking for a Python
job have a look at the link that I sent
in the meetup comments no there you go
that was a very short and sweet in our
moment we will go on to the pub and
you're welcome to come and join us for
continued conversation and first of all
I'm going to ask my fellow volunteers
and speakers and mark and many other
core contributors to stand up for a
round of applause and a chav staff so
gliomas or please stand up those
speakers and volunteers
we're always Thank You volunteers always
thank you speakers if you come to the
pub offer to buy them a beer or soft
drink whatever they want it's a good
thing to do somewhere floating around to
my green stars gonna have them battery
it's gonna come down to the front I've
lost track of those do we have any other
announcers we need to make I said we're
good so if you want to join the first Oh
in manual go on quickly what is it are
we doing a community would it be in the
pub off any manuals not physical in is
my jacket
alright so we're going to the pub it's
the banker hit the terms term right five
minute walk along follow the group of us
and then we'll see you next time thank
you
[Applause]